meanwhile tensions continue to simmer in
the nearby Taiwan Strait three Taiwanese
military boats are patrolling the Matsu
Islands after the defense Ministry
reported eight Chinese warships around
the island Beijing wrapped up three days
of military exercises practicing
encirclement of Taiwan on Monday
Richard haidarian is a senior lecturer
in international relations at the
University of Philippines joins us now
from Manila good to have you with us so
are the exercises aimed at sending
Beijing a message
well there's a lot going on here so one
backstory is of course the tension
around Taiwan with China conducting
large exercises there but the other one
is also the Philippines pivoting away
from the more Beijing friendly foreign
policy of previous president Rodrigo
duterte and now under Ferdinand Marcus
Jr the Philippines is emerging as the
new Star Ally of the United States is
emerging as a pivotal element of the U.S
integrated deterring strategy against
China so this war games are happening in
the South China Sea but initially some
part of this war games were supposed to
be in the north part of the Philippines
which were close to Taiwan but actually
opposition from Senator Aimee Marcos the
sister of the current president perhaps
convinced the military to kind of
relocate them nevertheless the size 17
000 troops more than 10 000 American
troops hundreds of troops from Australia
from Japan and thousands of troops from
the Philippines deployment of patriot
missile systems application of tactics
and strategies learned from the Ukraine
front by the NATO forces all of these
things are coming together not to
mention war games that are going to
simulate potential war with China in the
area when you put all of those things
together the message is very clear the
Philippines right now is a pivotal
element of U.S strategy in the region
against China
all right and we've got a situation
where the US is now allowed to use four
more Philippine military bases how much
of a strategic difference does that make
in the South China Sea
right uh so there were only generally
five bases that we're supposed to be
open to Americans not permanently but on
a rotational basis but president duterte
the former president wanted to keep a
good relationship with China so he did
not Implement that fully now Marcus is
coming in he added even four more so we
have nine bases being open to the
Americans among the four additional
bases two or three of them will be in
the north of the Philippines in Cagayan
and Isabella so they're very close to
Taiwan so that's why it's very important
but I think president Marcus Jr is still
trying to hedge his bets and not totally
provoke China because the Philippines
has not yet opened up its northernmost
bases it has bases in mavolis and fuga
Island which are just over 100 nautical
miles from taiwan's Southern Shores
those one have not been opened yet but
so far the Philippines has made a major
move towards revitalizing and upgrading
his alliance with the United States so
it remains to be seen what we'll be
trying as a response in the coming day
and months
are we seeing the rising tensions over
Taiwan now maybe resetting or
redirecting some of the relations in the
entire region
yeah absolutely there's a lot of
realignment happening here so everyone
has been discussing the Australia or
United States and UK the Orca submarine
deal the other trilateral that is coming
together is actually Japan Philippines
and U.S I call that the jaffa's alliance
or office in jaffa's they're parallel
quadrilateral uh groupings coming out
Australia Philippines Japan U.S all of
them have one thing in common a lot of
them are about a joint effort by U.S and
its allies to deter China invading
Taiwan this is not to provoke China but
to deter China to raise the cost of an
invasion of Taiwan because Taiwan is
extremely important to world economy and
it's at the fact that I left the United
States not to mention just too close to
the Philippines and Japan are to ignore
and what is happening how are relations
with the EU being realigned we saw
recently visits by EU leaders right to
China where is that going
yeah I think as far as Europe is
concerned there's a lot of internal
realignment happening there so our
understanding over the past few years
that the United Kingdom out of EU plus
Netherlands Germany France all of them
have been expanding their military
presence in this part of the world there
was an understanding that European
powers in America will kind of be in
lockstep in uh sending a strong message
to China about President Emmanuel
macron's recent visit to China where he
talked about strategic autonomy where he
seems to play Down the potential role
and Stakes for Europe when it comes to
Taiwan issue that is kind of jumbled
things I think that has kind of
reshuffled things but putting macron in
France aside I think there's an
understanding that more of the European
powers more or less share America's
concerns in this part of the world even
though they don't want to be as frontal
and aggressive as the United States but
by all indications we are already in the
middle of a new Cold War and in the
Philippines we're very much feeling that
all right thanks so much for your
thoughts on that